Hello everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Bell can today we have Ben Dickinson and Reggie watts for creative
control.
Let's go.
And middlemen.
Hello.
Hello her Clark.
So welcome guys.
Oh,
it's so good to finally be here in the future.
Yes,
I hear you.
I was waiting for so fucking long.
That was like,
was it 15?
Oh God.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
we had him in a terrible conference room upstairs,
so my apologies.
No windows.
It's okay,
man.
So,
uh,
Ben,
you wrote and directed this film,
so creative control,
uh,
you know,
it was a huge hit over in south by southwest and it was picked up by Amazon
studios.
So tell us about the film and,
uh,
just the plot line of the story.
The movie takes place in a tech ad agency,
uh,
where a guy is trying to sell,
testing out the first generation of augmented reality glasses system,
like a fully immersive ar system.
And in the course of,
uh,
playing around with them,
he
makes some very lifelike avatar of his best friend's girlfriend he's obsessed
with and it works out great.
There's no,
there's no problem.
No drama at all.
No problems are caused.
And um,
can you get his a weird sexual needs worked out and his relationship with his
girlfriend is totally functional and,
and move is actually only 20 minutes walk and it's actually just an
advertisement for augmented the company that's making the glasses.
It'll come out in the future.
So
where'd the idea come from this film?
Um,
frustration like were most writing comes from because writing is so hard.
If the only reason you would do it is if you just have like screaming demons,
like climbing inside your brain,
like I have to get this out.
Um,
so that's why I wrote it because I was just pissed.
I was just pissed off.
But where'd the idea come from?
So where was the judge of that?
Of I just the collective unconscious,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
No,
no.
Honestly Google glass came out.
Did someone,
did you guys know what?
You're a king,
what was it?
11 2011?
Yeah.
Nobody remembers.
No.
Have you guys been forbidden about talking about it every day?
Just like it never happened.
Never happened.
You're like,
yes,
we agree.
It's just for engineers.
Okay,
well,
in an alternate reality,
uh,
there was this product called Google glass,
which was wildly successful
when it came out.
Um,
I was like,
I see where this is going.
Like this has got to be basically an immersive smartphone,
but kind of really not in your way.
Um,
so it seemed obvious that was happening.
And so I started researching it and talking a lot with,
uh,
my friend Jake Lodwick,
who was in the movie who started,
um,
we started talking about just what will we want it to be like,
what would be an,
and the funny thing is that at the movie is a satire.
And,
uh,
but we,
the research and development of the,
of the tech aspect was a labor of love.
And like,
we were like,
we really wanted this technology.
So it's funny that then I'm like,
oh,
but it's a sad story.
And then,
so Reggie and I talked about a lot to everybody who I know who's super into
futurism type stuff was sending the article,
like every article who was coming out.
Um,
but I mean it's kind of hot and now it feels obvious,
right.
Where you were you guys friends before,
they didn't know each other before.
We don't like each other now.
No.
Yeah,
we knew we worked on several projects together.
Yeah.
Cause you were in music videos and Chet phones before that.
Right?
Yeah.
Merging.
I did a fuck shit stack video together.
Yup.
I'm still proud of that.
You kind of at that video,
it's real dumb.
Well,
so it should say,
so you've started the phone with me and you're the lead.
David,
I,
I didn't mention that.
So you do,
you start in the film,
but you also Reggie playing Reggie,
Reggie in the film.
And so when you're creating that,
were you,
was that just an idea that you'd like,
oh,
I have to get them in there or oh,
I have this role.
Oh,
you'd be perfect for it.
I wrote it for Reggie and it wasn't,
he wasn't in the initial
a couple of drafts.
Um,
there was,
there was something else in that place.
It took time for me to realize that I needed,
uh,
some comic relief.
Uh,
but also,
um,
I think Reggie has a really great way is a great relationship with technology in
general.
And,
um,
since I was kind of pointing out some of the darker aspects,
I wanted to that to be balanced out with this kind of court gesture character.
And also I mentioned that earlier,
like just narratively its functional because the main characters are all very
self serious and are very wrapped up in their neuroses.
So to have like a court jester come in and sort of shift the whole,
um,
the scale kind of in a way the scale of the,
can you talk about your role?
It's phenomenal.
Oh thanks.
So,
um,
I mean yeah,
I mean you know,
Ben just described it as myself of slightly in the future,
uh,
in this particular context where I'm kind of brought in inside of the movie as
my character has myself brought into the movie to kind of show what what's
possible with the technology,
um,
and to kind of drive it to some limits or maybe break some limits.
So,
um,
yeah,
it was,
uh,
it was pretty simple really.
I just kind of showed up and just riffed like I normally rift and um,
Ben was there to,
you know,
kind of steer it a little bit and try not to laugh and try it.
Yeah.
Try Not to laugh so many times he just be like,
and be like,
all right,
this being recorded
with film.
There's also
heck,
you have to go back to films to leverage one thing that you haven't,
you have,
sorry guys.
We're hold production.
I'm going to go to film school for a minute.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean it was a bit,
yeah,
it was very simple,
very straight forward.
Very,
very easy.
I understood exactly what the technology was about and uh,
something I've,
I've thought of her.
It was easy for Reggie to imagine himself,
you know,
a lot of time in the movie,
he's a Hologram,
you know,
kind of like,
kind of like the emperor and empire strikes back.
Just going to,
it's like,
I know who you are.
The same guys,
the,
anyways,
wait,
what?
Some of the best,
some of the funniest lines in the movie are,
are Reggie just made up on set.
So
you didn't really write that.
You were just kind of saying,
hey no,
he's just real.
He'll script for the movie.
We just showed up every day.
We just
so naturalistic.
I mean,
but you could've put him say,
hey this is what we're trying to get out of it,
but kind of go with it and improve it.
And the movie has a lot of master shots.
There's a lot of scenes that are all one shot in the movie.
Um,
but for the scenes that Reggie's and I tended to do coverage too.
So just so I can get,
um,
when he does sort of a stream of consciousness,
I have to be able to like loop stuff together sometimes with time in the movie.
So,
and that was uh,
it was great because the movie's so formerly rigorous.
But then when Reggie comes in everything kind of breeds a little bit.
Like,
oh there was one of my questions actually was about the one shots and stuff like
that.
Cause it's funny cause it's,
you necessarily don't know some of the first,
but you feel like,
oh my God,
like you're really,
really engaged.
So what was,
what would cause those are difficult to do.
So what was the planning for that and the decision just to do them?
Was it more of a challenge just for yourself?
Like,
Hey,
can I do this or was it just,
yeah,
some of it's just,
just being lazy and not wanting to do coverage.
Yeah.
Seeing if I can pull it off.
But,
um,
more importantly than that,
when you watch in movies,
we have time,
but it's not used very often.
Usually.
Um,
the editing is used in a way to kind of keep you in a trance a little bit.
There's like always forward momentum and stuff.
Um,
but when you shoot a scene,
especially of people talking in one shot,
you have the sense of it being more like real life,
you know,
that you're in a suspended moment of time.
Um,
and I think that has a subconscious effect,
um,
for,
for an audience,
even if they're not aware,
you just,
it just feels different.
And um,
yeah,
it makes it,
it makes it feel a little bit more real in some ways.
Just like,
it's like the people are real.
Um,
for sure.
And we were,
we were talking about this upstairs too,
was just about virtual reality and where it's going and with the stuff with
cardboard and oculus and Samsung and stuff like that.
So you guys are so you love it.
We were talking about that and where you that much into it beforehand as well or
was this just something you kind of stumbled upon?
Cause it was an idea,
um,
and to our air and uh,
yeah,
I didn't get into it until I needed it to as a narrative device in a movie.
And it wasn't even in the original and the original draft,
the component of ar glasses with kind of like a little flourish,
you know,
like,
uh,
it was like a theme.
Um,
but then when I was writing it,
you know,
movies kind of want to be,
as much as I always think I'm making more like a European art house movie.
I just,
I think I just love star wars when I was a kid and I always have this attraction
towards,
um,
even if I'm trying to deconstruct narrative,
it always seems to just kind of lean in the direction of genre even.
And so there's a lot of ideas in the,
I mean there's a,
there's a lot of ideas and worlds I'm trying to balance in the movie in order to
do that.
Um,
I just needed this through line.
And so then the,
the glasses became really the plot in a way I didn't expect.
Right.
And just by writing it in Reggie,
what was your experience with Vr and cause you're really into it.
You seem to love it.
Yeah,
I'm very into it.
Um,
uh,
yeah.
I mean,
ever since I was a little kid,
I was listening to the idea of being able to,
you know,
uh,
immerse herself in a reality convincingly and feel like you're actually there
and experience some other form of a living without,
without moving anywhere or,
you know,
just putting on something and suddenly you're there.
Um,
and then when lawnmower man came out and all of that stuff,
like the promise of like,
yeah,
we'll be in these weird suspended chairs and put it on these,
these things and somehow we'll feel like our bodies and it.
But anyways,
I was just always very interested in transporting myself to other realities that
seem just purely imaginative aside from actually just using your imagination.
So when the,
when the second round of Vr came around and you know,
maybe the mid two thousands where the promise of like,
Oh,
we fixed the parallax problem,
the problem where people put on these headsets and get really,
really dizzy cause it's not functioning the way our eyes work in the real world.
Once they fixed that all sudden something promising started to emerge.
And now we're,
you know,
we're in that moment where we're about to have access to really powerful pieces
of hardware.
And it's just the beginning.
So VR and Ar,
which essentially is just an evolution of Vr,
um,
is a very exciting to me because it hopefully can provide some interesting
transparent technological wizardry in our life that doesn't make us feel like
we're taking wrenches to technology and constantly trying to fix it all the
time.
And the movie actually explores a lot of the pitfalls of augmented reality and
kind of the dangers of that.
What scares you about the current place we're in with Vr?
Ar Robots,
uh,
like they get through an robot.
Thanks for mentioning robot.
I mean,
I mean the doomsday scenarios are,
uh,
easy to talk about an imagine with all of that stuff.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm what excites you then?
What excites me?
What excites you about it?
Um,
well,
it's happening.
Yeah.
So
it's true.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to be interested in the world around me.
Um,
if I can,
we can move on.
Terrible question.
No,
it's not.
You know what?
I don't know.
I was just thinking,
I was just thinking about my yard and just
why am I here?
It's probably just dripping.
I got what I got excited about Vr at Sundance this year.
Uh,
we had,
uh,
we did a VR project,
like a 10 minute short film that was at Sundance this year and I kind of was
like,
Eh,
I mean I like doing it,
but once we went to Sundance and I saw a couple of other pieces that people were
doing in the breadth of what people are doing,
um,
in Vr,
I actually did get really excited and it made me feel like a little kid again.
Um,
which,
you know,
if you could sell feeling like a little kid again in a pill,
you'd be rich.
I remember,
I remember a kid on the back of the bus telling me about my lawnmower man.
That was the first time I ever encountered.
And then I remember him being like,
yeah,
and then like doing like virtual reality and they're like having sex.
And I was like,
Whoa,
this movie's so amazing.
Like nothing like this.
And then the movie that I imagined,
it was so much better than when I finally got to see it.
Oh my God,
that was really disappointed.
I was really disappointed when I came and started
the VR.
It doesn't work very well.
You know Reggie's actually in La.
He projected his consciousness.
Reggie Pod,
I'm just soliciting slightly over here.
Remember it a science fiction,
like young adults science fiction book from the 80s
and they,
they sort of,
it's all about telepresence.
Like they shoot a kid's consciousness to a body on Mars.
We can visit as ont or something like that.
Oh No,
maybe I just made it.
That was awesome.
I thought it was awesome when I was a kid cause quickly Google it,
Richard,
you know,
you're one of the most,
you'd owe God some kind of one of the most unique comedians and artists and
musicians and where so it really showcases in the movie.
It's phenomenal.
And it's like,
well this is,
this is completely,
this isn't the Reggie,
I know you were playing like a heightened version of yourself,
but where do these influences come from for you simply and comedically?
I mean a lot,
a lot of it just come.
I guess if I think of the,
the basic essence of where it comes from,
it's just being able to transport your imagination,
to transport yourself through imagination,
like reinterpreting the environment around you,
about seeing things differently
to full immersion or watching a television show or a movie or making,
you know,
being a kid and playing with Gi joes and the dirt.
Um,
like all of anything that incorporates and engage is my imagination.
And that's technology.
That's art,
it's conversations,
it's colors,
it's,
it's really any input that you have access to as a biological organism.
So for me,
it's just,
um,
it's a nonstop interest in,
uh,
life and possibility and reality and,
and most importantly,
connecting with people I don't like making,
I don't like being involved in things that are just one sided or cold.
Um,
I like to take things that engineers come up with,
um,
who have their own set of criteria and imaginative process and take that and
figure out a way to connect people with that technology that's still engages
that feeling that you're talking about feeling like a little kid again because
otherwise it's just a bunch of,
it's just a bunch of stuff that you think is cool but are ultimately not really
that interested in and well,
yeah,
I was just thinking about a technology debt that sets us up and allows us to
play as opposed to technology that's designed to be addictive and um,
I think we don't talk about that enough.
Like,
and a lot of times an op Ed,
it's like,
or p people,
people don't realize that the addiction is intentional I think.
And they blame themselves a lot of the time.
You know,
it's just,
it's,
so is that your process is really just trying to like tap into that inner child
and the inner interest and stuff.
It's like,
how do you,
like when you're coming up with a new sets,
a new
album,
whatever the case may be,
what is that to come up with that?
Do you lock yourself away in a room?
Are you going around and watching other artists and trying to get ideas or,
no,
I'm,
I'm always going for the absolute absolute laziest way to create anything,
which is,
uh,
I think it's underrated,
underrated and to,
it really is,
it really is because for me,
like if I'm like,
if someone's like,
hey man,
you want to record a song in the studio?
Uh,
usually I am,
I just say,
okay,
make sure that the mic is set up in advance before I get there.
I'm just going to show up.
I do a bunch of stuff on the microphone.
I'm going to quickly adjust things,
structured things very quickly,
and I'm going to let an expert who will my trust aesthetically kind of finish
the idea because I don't want to waste time again,
bogging myself down and,
um,
in technical particulars that I could,
but my role is to really just channel creativity and to surround myself with
people that are so good at what they do,
that it's very easy for them to understand what's happening when I put something
out there and,
um,
or to utilize me in a way like Ben did in this,
in this movie where he's like,
I know this guy does,
I know what he likes and let's just put them in this situation.
And yeah,
of course it's going to work out,
you know?
So for me,
creativity or like thinking about like an album or anything,
I want to make it the quickest way possible with the least amount of time
required for filmmaking film that.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I mean it's funny because,
no,
but,
but that reminds me like,
oh,
even like,
uh,
like for instance if I'm doing a television,
a comedy Bang Bang or something like that and they're like,
your mark is here and I start waving my arms and they're like,
oh,
I actually could you just make sure your arms are a little bit higher if I'm
like,
this is moving in the wrong direction.
It's moving in the wrong direction.
It's like,
it's like the production or technology should be in service of imagination.
So you should be prepared for anything to happen.
You should have contingencies to be able to,
to make sure that creativity can express itself in the maximum way.
That's not to say that being a total dick and like ruin things like,
but just,
but just like,
we are not prepared to hear.
No,
no.
It's like I'm laying over here.
Me.
This is California,
right?
Everyone's just like either word.
Hey,
it's Cali man.
It's close to humble.
I don't know.
I don't know what that means.
It's great though.
They go back
on just the,
you know,
you went from,
uh,
the short,
you know,
film narrative and for format and music videos unit first winter,
which was very,
very much smaller in scale.
And then you went to this,
which was way grander,
way more complex.
That's a huge jump.
Was there,
was there difficulties there or were you nervous or anything?
Oh yeah,
I was terrified for like a whole year.
I was just in a state of constant panic for about a year.
Um,
okay.
So,
yeah,
I mean it was worried.
Yeah.
What was the,
what were the struggles in trying to adapt to that bigger format,
the craziness of it and just trying to get this film made?
Well,
I mean it's,
it's just magnified.
It feels like the same experience.
You have slightly more people on set obviously,
but,
um,
I've done some pretty big commercials and stuff,
so like I'm familiar,
I'm like comfortable with having a lot of people around when you're trying to do
it.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
Uh,
I think one thing that I haven't thought about this a lot,
but one thing that's difficult when you move to a bigger size production is
everything is much more organized and it has to be because you've got trucks
full of lights and shit and um,
you're on location and it's crazy and you were,
so the script becomes this sort of Bible in a way,
but not just for the words.
I represents a certain amount of time,
a certain amount of hours.
And what tends to happen that I think is unfortunate and I tried to figure out
how to fight it,
is that uh,
the script comes to concrete and you'll have an,
you know,
daddy's like,
she missed that line.
She knew that and I'm like,
it doesn't matter.
Like we're trying to get the scene.
But even I got into that mentality where I'm just shooting the script that I
wrote in the past rather than responding to what's happening right now.
Because even though there's this huge apparatus,
you are still at a certain moment in time in a certain place with actual human
beings.
And you're trying to get at an essence in the particular words that you wrote.
I mean,
unless you're doing some very highly tuned comedy writing,
like the Coen brothers or something,
which I'm not a,
but even then you have to be,
it's very difficult to get back into the present moment.
And you have a lot of,
you know,
guys around,
you might've been three hours lighting it and they're going to be grumpy if you
decide to change the shot at the last minute.
But you just have to do it and let the be like,
be grumpy at who,
um,
and,
but also to push yourself out of that comfort zone when you're in a bigger,
when you know,
when you just have more,
there,
you have more people supporting you.
Um,
and that can sometimes feel like a burden.
but actually it can be liberating if you remember to keep it fresh.
And actually I learned so much about I'm doing that,
not just creatively,
but just in my life from hanging around Reggie,
slight,
slightly less than erotic around Reggie.
I'm not saying you're responsible for me.
It's a little bit.
Thank you.
Thank you for channel.
Yeah,
he just sucks it out of my brain.
Um,
so what was the biggest thing that you took away from this film that's going to
help you learn on your next film specifically?
I'll actually on the next one,
I actually want to go back to being a little looser with,
with how I shoot it.
I mean,
as it,
you know,
this one is very precise and I still want to do that,
but I,
I,
I want to start playing a little bit more jazz and the next one
and I'm dialing the writing can always be a better writer.
I gotcha.
And was there anything that was not in this film that you really want to get in
there but had to be cut because of timing?
Oh yeah.
There's like six scenes that are cut out,
but I really like,
um,
it'll be on the DVD specialists.
There you go.
Does anyone use DVDs anymore?
How,
how do you like look at Dvds,
specials in commentary?
That's so hard.
I mean an apple,
it does.
Like if you buy a movie that you do get those extras.
I just rewatched it and Google places.
Oh,
you do?
Okay.
Have you watched the passenger last week?
Oh No,
I can't get it in there.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Um,
what was the toughest scene to film?
Because like I said,
as soon as I started seeing the one shots,
I was like,
Oh God,
that one must have been,
but what,
what was the toughest thing to get right.
And,
and film the toughest thing to get right was the last scene of the movie.
Yeah.
Um,
and we actually reshot him,
um,
completely re shot.
It was cause the,
you didn't like the original idea or just wasn't sure it was the same scene,
but,
um,
I miscalculated what the ending needed to be.
It was the same scene but with a different energy.
Basically.
W I don't know,
I don't want to ruin it,
but,
um,
you know,
the,
that big fight at the end,
uh,
why when I reached out and I definitely rewrote it to be funnier and less full
of hatred.
So the honestly I realized what I did was I like,
I realized there needed to be more love in that scene in general.
And um,
I was being,
I was being too,
the first time I shot it,
I was,
um,
I was being too cynical.
I gotcha.
I mean,
I didn't agree with myself in retrospect.
It's good that you could see that though and be like,
oh,
we got to re shoot this as well.
It was hard to admit,
but then when I finally admitted it and then dumped some cold water over my head
a few times,
I was able to go on,
we should be a clu challenge.
Right.
Is that a challenge to promote civil,
uh,
civil rights?
Right.
I've heard of that.
How do you feel the future of Vr and film?
We'll cross paths.
Do you think they'll combine in any way?
I don't.
I don't know that I would want to spend an hour and a half,
two hours in a Vr headset.
Um,
so I think,
I think even if you were in like a projected room,
that sounds too long.
So I think more likely it's going to a new narrative forms will,
will emerge,
will be on my desk and they'll be a little shorter than movies I think.
Yeah.
I think Vr is,
does is definitely its own thing.
It's,
it's um,
it's really,
it's really its own thing and that's exciting.
That's actually refreshing as opposed to being another type of screen and other,
yeah.
Like another delivery device,
another delivery of cram it in another whole,
cram it in there.
No,
it's just like its own thing.
It's great.
It's like there is a new thing,
there is a new thing.
It's that,
yeah.
And it's exciting because uh,
it is very much up for grabs how we want to use it.
Yeah.
Then you mentioned that the original draft as good didn't really have as much of
kind of ar in it.
Um,
I'm wondering,
it's like the technology became a bigger part of it.
Did the storyline shift and then make you go,
hm.
I mean that technology,
this relationship with don one way when it turned out differently.
And how's that kind of like parallel to how you think about like,
I guess transition to like real life and might affect relationships?
Yeah,
that's an interesting point.
Um,
in some ways,
uh,
you could tell this story without technology.
I probably hasn't been done during the French new wave like 10 times.
Uh,
basically like the guy has,
is not happy at home and then he has a fantasy about how it would be better
another way and either carries out that fantasy or just imagines that there's
that.
Um,
was that cue what Cq?
Cq?
Yeah.
Which was an individualist that time.
But,
and then there's that Romer movie called a love in the afternoon,
I think is the whole movie is just about middleclass French guy imagining
cheating on his wife.
And at the end he just not to,
it's a great movie.
I just ruined it.
It's really subtle.
So I think,
I think you could tell that story without technology,
but I will say this in the earlier drafts,
the movie was really more like compare contrast David Juliet,
like he's in technology,
she's into yoga,
he's like doing this fantasy world that she's kind of like trying to get more
into robotics,
but it's also a fantasy world.
And it was much more literary in that way.
Like I was really trying to show two points of view,
having an argument.
But then once the technology thing came in,
Juliet gets like marginalized a little bit.
And that's part of my frustration sometimes with with film narrative.
If it was a TV show,
I could have been like third episode is all from Juliet's point of view.
Do you know what I mean?
So,
um,
yeah,
in a weird way the technology did marginalize the human relationship for me to
tell the story about technology,
marginalizing human relationships as my human relationships were being
marginalized by making this film.
So
thanks.
Thanks for asking.
I feel better.
Um,
so I saw the movie last night and I loved it and I really loved how like
natural,
a lot of those scenes were.
And some were like cringe worthy.
How,
like national day where it was cringeworthy awkward,
like,
Oh God,
no.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's really,
I say that,
oh,
you're going to say that?
No.
Um,
but I wanted to know how do you take it?
So a lot of people were kind of talking after the movie and seven saying it's,
it's kind of a 2016 version of her.
Like,
how do you take that?
Is that a compliment?
Is,
did it have any part in how you came up with certain things or do you play off
of it at all?
Well,
we shot the movie before hurricane out.
I didn't have the chance to respond to it and that way,
um,
I knew it was coming out and I was like,
blah,
uh,
her as a romance.
I mean,
I mean from a standpoint of literature,
it's like on the opposite end of the spectrum of s as a satire,
um,
even though they're describing a similar phenomenon.
So,
um,
in a way I welcome the comparison because that movie cost like 40 times more
money.
And you know what I mean?
It's like,
I'll take it,
like compare,
compare it away to her.
Um,
but I think it's an interesting double feature,
uh,
because yeah,
they're really a tech,
you know,
approaching it from a different point of view.
Um,
there's no political reality in her whatsoever,
from what I can tell.
It's just not concerned with politics or economics,
um,
that much.
And I mean,
really what's weird about her is that it's [inaudible] she's an authentic AI,
right?
So that means that the company that's selling or a slave traders,
cause she's conscious,
you know what I mean?
Like there's all this other stuff in there that's,
you could just look at it.
You can just be more negative.
It can be a negative Nancy,
watch her and then you'd make my movie,
but we'll actually,
it's not so great.
Yeah.
Plus plus the plus the construct in the movie is,
it's just a composite.
It's not alive in any way.
Well,
that's important too.
Like,
uh,
yeah,
there's no authentic AI.
And my movie,
it's really just,
just his own fantasies projected back at him,
which is kind of like a different,
he has an authentic Joaquin as I like to call them.
Has A,
has an authentic relationship,
a real relationship with an AI.
Uh,
but in my movie,
David is just in a relationship with something that he's creating.
So he's uh,
created,
uh,
it's,
it's a Pygmalion,
the sex scenes.
Is that just awkward or was it awkward to pretend to masturbate in front of
entire crew?
Yeah.
It's weird to ought to be the director of,
be like,
okay guys,
that was a great shot.
Now I'm going to
sit down and do the most private thing.
Pretend
that was a trip.
Yeah,
that was really weird.
Like you wrote,
it is funny.
It is funny to suddenly,
yeah,
be a naked like on a couch.
Getting like having an entire crew film.
You,
you see where I'm going with this.
It's like,
it's like the most masturbatory
pause
dude.
Max Mass.
It was mostly like,
how have I put myself in this situation?
It's amazing.
It was needed for the film most.
Yeah.
The most narcissistic moment of my entire life.
There we go.
Really Weird.
Hey guys.
Next question though,
is really the related to writing and how,
I mean with all that filmmaking takes with the writing and all the steps,
the process,
how do you be your own boss and how do you set goals for yourself and deadlines?
Um,
um,
I take a lot of naps.
Um,
I have a completely erratic,
a sleeping schedule.
I vacillate between drinking lots of red wine and not drinking at all for a
week.
Don't forget that we'd know
smoking weed with Reggie reg.
Well,
eating it,
eating it.
Um,
promethazine over over a peanut man.
Got The permit.
The scene going on.
I don't know.
No,
I don't.
I,
I'm terrible.
I'm terrible at staying on schedule.
But once you have a bunch of people involved in money's getting spent,
you just have to,
you just kind of like get taken along for the ride.
The,
the early part
of generating the energy to make that happen.
I don't know.
Do you think that it helped?
I mean,
do you think that it helped after you go your first pres project off the,
off the ground and it kind of built momentum and you got in,
you became known.
Do you think it helped kind of being,
being accountable to more,
more people?
I mean,
it just Kinda gets rolling and then when you first start off,
you're like,
I had this idea.
It's only in my mind,
but I'm pretty sure you're going to love it.
But after you've made a few things,
you can be like,
the New York Times says that I'm a person was a name.
You know what I mean?
That you should,
you should know about and it starts to become more concrete for people.
Um,
so yeah.
So then you're just starting off with a little bit more of a platform,
a way to give people a context to take you seriously.
And that's,
uh,
yeah,
that's
part of part of life
moving through life and things and lots of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
going off of that,
you know,
balancing writing,
directing,
enacting is that,
it's got to be incredibly tough.
Yeah.
I wouldn't recommend it.
I wouldn't recommend that anyone do that.
But you didn't want anyone else playing that star role that was oh no,
no.
I asked disease to do it.
It was the first person I asked was,
is he's an sorry,
really,
that he didn't do it and he was,
he was like,
he said no.
And then I asked a bunch of other people and they all said no.
And then,
uh,
one guy sort of said yes.
And then I talked to him like these are known actors that I was talking to when
one guy sort of said yes,
but then I did a phone call with him,
um,
and he was the opposite of cool.
So I was like,
don't want to do that.
Um,
so then I started,
then I was auditioning like New York theater actors,
but at that point,
um,
these actions under the name,
so they had,
there was no value being added to the film from a standpoint of distribution or
raising the money.
So at that point I was like,
I know a real efficient way to do this.
I can play the role myself.
And I,
I felt that I could do it.
You did great.
Thanks.
No,
it was just interesting the balance,
but I can't even imagine.
That's hard.
Yeah.
That's like schizophrenia because I'm directing and I'm like analyzing it and
then I'm in the scene acting trying to pretend that it's real and not analyze
anything.
And then watching playback,
that was weird.
Yeah,
it helps.
I think it helped me like get go crazy a little bit,
which my character goes crazy.
So it was like a,
yeah,
it was like method filmmaking,
straws to filmmaking.
So Reggie is a really interesting to hear you like kind of talk about how,
you know,
you're creative force and that's like your strong suit and you surround yourself
with a team of very talented people to help you,
um,
help it stuff and producing a,
at what point did you realize in your career that that's what you needed to do?
Was there a time when you tried to do it all and like how,
how did you discover that?
I mean,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a good question.
That there definitely was a point at which I was like,
you know,
the music I would make,
I would,
I would record it and I multitrack it and I would eat it and I would do,
I would do the whole production process.
But then,
you know,
I work with an amazing producer and then I realize,
oh,
I'll have to do is just like play it,
play the play the idea or you know,
explain the vibe that I want to bring across and kind of someone got it and then
also added a little bit of their own thing and I loved it.
And,
and then that freed me up to do more creatively.
And so expanding that are the early times like making films,
you know,
early video,
Internet,
video times.
I was definitely doing that myself and experimented with editing and I just got
bored of editing.
It was,
it was a lot of hard work and I started like losing focus as to what it was that
I was making.
And then when I worked with an editor,
someone who just had a mind for that,
I could see it from the outside and be like,
oh,
that was great.
Oh,
I wouldn't have thought of doing that.
So realizing that creativity,
like the,
the only thing that I can do is just protect my creativity.
And by protecting that,
I mean making sure that I can maximize it at all times and having a modular
system of experts that I can form different,
you know,
kind of protein structures to,
to express creative ideas in the various mediums and,
and the most difficult medium,
the most complex medium would be film.
And,
uh,
and that's something that luckily working with Ben and friends of his that I've
worked with have yielded results where I really trust this system of people that
I'm working with.
How can I then continue that journey?
Um,
uh,
that usually requires a lot of inner,
a great amount of energy and resources to create.
So that's an exciting thing to realize and to free yourself from.
I think a lot of,
a lot of it is about tuning,
um,
tuning up communication.
It's like those protein connectors are,
is communication between you and the team.
And like,
um,
just like in any relationship,
the better the communication,
the more creativity can flow.
Cause there's,
there's more,
there's more avenues you have to travel on.
And it's like,
yeah,
building yourself a team of people with whom you're having,
not only are you communicating that you're having an amazing conversation with
all these different people,
um,
and he trusted their aesthetic.
Exactly.
Because trusting aesthetics is like a,
it's a difficult thing.
Someone can technically be incredible,
but they may not understand where you're coming from or at least resonate on a
similar frequency where they can then join,
join forces with.
Yeah.
Some of it is just energetic frequencies.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Like with tuning it up,
you got to like fine tune those relationships and make sure that you're
communicating in multiple levels,
you know?
Yeah.
Like the dream,
the dream world,
very important.
Very important to be exactly like it.
I'm wondering how technology actually impacted the act of making the film
itself.
Like,
were there any particular technologies that in their new that had a big impact
on making the film or did augmented reality actually impact the film itself?
Oh,
that's a great question.
Um,
there's a couple of shots in the film that are from the point of view of the
glasses and that was GoPros.
Um,
but you're,
yeah,
we were able to shoot I think at that time,
four k on the Gopro.
Um,
so when we struck it down it actually looks pretty good.
Like the,
the quality was pretty good.
Um,
so wouldn't have been able to do that a few years before that.
Definitely just having just camera that I can mount on the head to be the
glasses was huge.
Um,
I mean I haven't,
I still haven't played around with a real ar system.
Reggie and I are going to go to at tomorrow and check it out.
I took the hollow Lens.
You did?
Yeah.
It's great.
Yeah,
it's really good.
No,
but that was all I,
I haven't experienced it still to this day,
so it could be her sing to see,
having seen the movie and then wearing hololens are just like,
oh yeah,
that's very,
very possible.
I mean,
the graphics are more dull and the colors are very good,
but like at least it stays rock solid no matter where you move,
the things that you see are staying in place.
And that's,
yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
So I'm looking to get paid as a consultant if anybody wants to.
Okay.
Well,
thank you so much for meeting
[inaudible].